the truth matters which is why holding
people accountable has been a major
theme of the show we've investigated
hate crimes stood up to anti-trump
professors confronted those who believe
meat reinforces gender stereotypes
whatever that means and fought back
against bullies who harass people here's
a look back at some of the most
confrontational and outrageous moments
of waters world
this is the third floor apartment where
the hate crime took place right here
hello
seems like there might have actually
been children in this apartment which is
even more
despicable this is exactly where
this young man was tortured
by these people right here in this
corner he was cowering he was scared
where they repeatedly abused him
on facebook live you have footage of you
saying off crackers and awful pigs would
you like to apologize for that you don't
have food to change i didn't talk about
offering pigs and i said you ain't gonna
do nothing and i mocked
no now you're changing what you're
saying i actually have the transcript
right here
not an opinion that's what i say all
right well facts are facts thank you
very much i've got enough guts to show
that i'll show the whole thing yeah i'm
sure you will have a few questions
sorry students shouldn't open their
hearts to white trump supporters
what kind of thing is that to say
president trump is gonna kill people
how do you justify that
this isn't a cult this is a classroom
professor
i wanted to talk about your behavior on
the flight sir
you regret
verbally abusing ivanka trump on the
plane
you harassed a woman with her baby on a
flight are you proud of that
real class act aren't you now you're
afraid to show your face
i'm giving you an opportunity to
apologize sir
nothing to say
were you high when you sued chris kyle's
widow was i high
you know that's a
question and i expect it from someone
from fox she's suffering a lot of pain
no she isn't how do you know that
because insurance pays for it all she
hasn't paid one cent how do i know it
it's my case
the case got overturned because the
truth came out insurance is paying for
all of it would you apologize to her why
would i apologize i didn't do anything
you only apologize if you've done
something wrong pal
sat next to a journalist from the new
york times last night who told me
melania is a hooker i noticed you didn't
really cover this story on your website
perez why you did did you i didn't see
it on there why couldn't i find it on
the website
you probably didn't look closely enough
just it's on there right now if you want
to go search the melania trump category
and i agree not because i saw it was
covered in the lawsuit melania had but
this actually wasn't maybe i'm wrong go
ahead no we covered it i can send you
the link right now if you would like
[Music]
perez you know we don't have time for
you to go through the website because
like i said i couldn't find it there
either but if you just answer my
question we'll assume you have it
if fox news
journalist
called michelle obama a hooker
wouldn't you find that offensive and
wouldn't you find that on your website
pretty quickly
uh yes what's with it about smearing the
first lady of the united states
that the left and people in hollywood
find so attractive i could just read her
body language when she's with her
husband 30 year old from upstate new
york who last week was evicted under
court order from his parents home after
living there rent-free for eight years
mike where are you right now
right on to my cousin's sister's house
okay so you're still technically living
with the family if fiscal responsibility
is something that's important to you
yeah don't you think you might have
saved some money and been fiscally
responsible in your personal life
oh i didn't think of that you know
that's a good point is o.j innocent or
guilty
o.j simpson is innocent
say it again he is innocent o.j simpson
did not kill nicole brown simpson
according to our judicial system he is
innocent so let me ask you this jesse
has there been collusion with russia
between trump and russia no okay there's
no collusion okay well hey no collusion
oj is innocent it's a win-win yeah but
there's no evidence of collusion between
trump and russia there was blood all
over the place there's two dead bodies
have you found dead russians in in trump
tower i mean come on wendy we haven't
used your birth been indicted use your
brain not for delusion
dodgeball
game that uses the human body as a
target it's the only game that does this
and students and adults both are
reporting that it's a vehicle for
bullying the reason is that first of all
it's an elimination game and we don't
recommend those in the pe curriculum
what's wrong with elimination games
well it
systematically eliminates players isn't
that like the same thing as ring around
the rosie
yeah exactly so would you are you
against ring around the rosie two
uh well actually that i believe and doug
duck goose is also in the hall of shame
now in the u.s you're learning how to
play you're learning your limitations
your strengths isn't the rule if you you
know if you're saying if you're some fat
slow kid you're not getting targeted all
the time you can catch the ball
if it gets thrown out at you and then
the other guy that throws it has to go
to jail eating meat is bad for you it's
bad for the country and it reinforces
gender stereotypes apparently what we
consume
what we put on our bodies
the things we buy and put in our
households
are fundamentally political acts i'm
having a steak right now because i'm
starving i hear you i wish i could have
half of that but this doesn't look vegan
and i'm trying to be vegan you're a
vegan is this
bad that i'm eating meat
if you go hunting that's a totally
different story right the blood's on
your hands
right now you're kind of just enjoying
the benefit and the blood's on someone
else's hands and that's not very fair
it'd be great if we had universal health
care for our animals animals that could
be expensive if you
give birth which you're refusing to do
but if you get pregnant and give birth
what would be the problem what we're
looking at in the next few decades the
end of the century is a worldwide famine
food shortages across the world do you
even have a family i do are you worried
about them are you worried about their
features
no i remember when all the scientists
can just continue to remember when all
the scientists told me that the world
was the center of the universe what's
happening why it was wrong
it was wrong
y2k was wrong
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else